all right boys i have a question i want
to know is there any anime out there
that
you you know maybe have a hard take on
like an anime that you think is
either really good uh an anime that you
like that is highly praised and
widely accepted to be amazing that you
think isn't that good or is there a show
that everyone thinks [ __ ] that you think
is pretty good
um jerry's already had his with [ __ ]
school days
cause you know i really like the cowboy
bebop dub but
the show itself i didn't think it was
like that good i'm gonna be honest like
i liked it i liked it
but i didn't think it was like the
masterpiece worthy like everyone says
it's like
i i i hate that i can't disagree with
you like it's
like it's like the the job i preferred
samurai championships
yes yes yes nah now you're million
i was about to say i have the exactly
the same opinion just with samurai
no samurai was a millionaire to me like
this like i i
i don't know what it was about samurai
champagne i thought the story the style
ever the music was like amazing and the
music gets amazing in how google but
don't be wrong
but like the reasons why i liked cowboy
bebop was
well won the dub and two nothing to do
with the story i thought the story was
kind of like all right
okay i just i just feel like cowboy
bebop had some really interesting ideas
because
it's it's kind of like kabul bebop is
isn't like a
long like it doesn't have like a very
long overarching story arc
it's more of these individual ideas that
you know
that one tanabe wanted to explore and i
thought it had some really
good ideas and so did samurai shampoo
but i don't know something about samurai
shampoo just made me feel like
the ideas just weren't as interesting on
an individual level
like can you can you sit here and and
like say to me that cowboy bop deserves
to be like
in the top five as it always is on every
single yes really
yeah really top five okay like when i
see it like of
all time like when i see it it's like
those people who put citizen kane at
number one on dude it's like
it's like yeah i know movies citizen
kane's my favorite i know the movie
is a rosebud my favorite quote it's like
it's like i
when i see that on someone's like top
five i immediately think they're like
trying too hard to be a christian yeah
because to me like again i
i don't think of anime in like a
critical sense yeah most of the time i
just thought when i watched it i was
like
it's really [ __ ] cool tons of style i
just thought the story was kind of meh
yeah i mean if you if you go into it for
like a big story
then it's just a show okay so okay so
what about the samurai shampoo story was
good then i okay it's been a long time
since i watched both
same here same yeah but i don't know i
remember just because they're really
having [ __ ] a ton of fun every single
episode of samurai
to me to me the story and like character
like how much i enjoyed the story and
the characters about samurai champlain
cowboy bebop were around equal
yeah it was everything else around the
show like the music
the soundtrack like the aesthetics like
the animation stuff yeah that made
samurai champ blue just that much better
i mean like
i did not give a [ __ ] about the [ __ ]
annoying kid
on cali bebop i mean i i didn't give a
[ __ ] about foo
like for like what what were they trying
to do again finding
samurais like sunflowers like the plot
doesn't matter in either [ __ ] show
i just i like the characters more than
samurai champagne i
like i thought because we had only three
of them it was like we got a lot more
time to like
flesh it out whereas they just brought
this [ __ ] sidekick character and a
dog and i'm like why
i get to be fair i love iron though yeah
mine is like one of the coolest anime
characters of all time
i think mugen was cooler to be honest
with you just saying i think mugen was
way cooler than spike
i think spike is dope but if i had to
like say which one was cool i'd
definitely move again
yeah but spike can meet spike and beat
me
my dad looks for microsoft
be able to survive aids my character can
beat up your character have you thought
about that
what's moving gonna do swing your
samurai sword mike a spy can just
[ __ ] shoot you man
i like spiegel [ __ ] like
i mean i don't know i i don't
has been one of those shows that i do
think is great but
it's just whenever i see it in top fives
i'm like you're just chatting out of
your ass
like yeah